hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten heute gibt es ganz klassisches
denn ich möchte heute streusel trager
machen sowie die aus der bäckerei nur
eben dass es selbst gemacht sind und
natürlich auch deswegen viel besser
schmecken wenn wir essen sie dann auch
gleich frisch ich mache die aus einem
ganz normalen hefeteig und dann kommen
da eben noch streusel drauf und bei mir
kommt noch ein bisschen johannes bei
marmelade rein einfach damit so ein
bisschen fruchtiger wird und ich zeige
euch jetzt einfach mal meine zutaten für
den hefeteig brauche ich 500 gramm mehl
160 gramm zucker normalerweise nämlich
immer 80 aber ich zunächst nur 60 weil
er noch streusel draufkommen
hier habe ich drei bis vier esslöffel
warmes wasser einen würfel hefe 200
milliliter mädels die ist immer warm 80
gramm weiche butter einen teelöffel salz
und ich nehme so ein bisschen von meinem
mann in der schoten extrakt dann brauche
ich wie gesagt johannes lade ich habe
jetzt hier im st
das sind 250 gramm und für die streusel
brauchen wir gleich 125 gramm kalte
butter 125 gramm zucker und 150 gramm
mehl und später vorstand nur noch ein
bisschen puder zucker und zitronensaft
für ein bisschen glasur ich stelle jetzt
erst mal ein hefeteig her und macht es
wieder in der küchenmaschine aber es
geht auch ganz gut per hand zuerst
nehmen die jetzt die würfel den würfel
hefe und löst ihn in dem wasser auf
einfach so ein bisschen
kurz verrühren
angebliche ziel ein bisschen zucker mit
dazu einfach damit diese nahrung bekommt
und gleichauf gehen kann
das könnten wir jetzt kurz stehen lassen
den vorteig sozusagen aber ich
verarbeite es gleich weiter ich gebe
jetzt diese mischung hier in meiner
küchenmaschine
da kommt die milch mit dazu und ich
spüre jetzt ist klar so ein bisschen aus
wie zucker drin
man kommt da das ei mit rein und etwa
drei viertel von ihr
den rest gibt es gleich nach und nach
mit dazu hier noch der restliche zucker
und die butter kommt auch erst später
mit dazu und ein bisschen von der
vanille kunden
nur so ein paar tropfen und das versuche
ich jetzt erstmalig kann jetzt hier auch
temperatur einstellen also ich mach das
ganze jetzt auf 30 grad und für lass es
einfach verkneten
das gebe ich noch das salz mit rein
und doch weiterhin vom restlichen mail
immer mal ein bisschen
bis einfach ein glatter teig entsteht
jetzt kann auch die butter mit dazu
und jetzt lasse ich das ganze etwa 56
minuten verkneten wissen wir fertig
entsteht dass ich dann so ein bisschen
vom schlüssel rand löst
und ihr seht ist der teig hat sich jetzt
richtig vom schüssel rand gelöst jetzt
nehme ich ihnen ganz kurz raus damit ich
so eine kugel daraus formen kann geht am
besten mit einer tankkarte und richtig
schön weich aber klebt einfach nicht
mehr und es ist eben wichtig dass man
den teig geknetet damit einfach nicht
mehr gelebt es war mich daraus einfach
kurz zu eine schöne kugel auch jetzt
nicht zu viel mehr nehmen damit der teig
jetzt auch nicht fester wird und jetzt
einfach von außen mache ihnen den teig
geben wo man sieht ist auch das erweist
doch richtig mache ich jetzt kurz e mail
hin und her rollen
und ich gebe ich noch ein bisschen mehr
in meine schlüssel rein und klickt im
teig wieder zurück wir decken auch
nochmal mit mädel und lass ihn jetzt
einfach aufgehen
das gab es jetzt wieder hier in der
küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt auch
einfach so ein bisschen entweder im
deckel drauf geben oder einfach so ein
bisschen frischhaltefolie und den teig
ist etwa eine halbe stunde einfach in
der küche stehen lassen oder im ofen der
etwa auf 30 grad aufgeheizt ist und ich
mach das jetzt einfach das dauert es
ungefähr eine halbe stunde und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder mein
hefeteig ist mittlerweile aufgegangen
ich zeige ich euch auch gleich mein gott
heute versprechen und ich mache jetzt
einfach mal kurz die sträuße
entweder könnte es jetzt schnell mit den
händen verkneten oder einfach mit einem
mixer machen
also ich gebe da jetzt einfach die
zutaten in einen mixer das geht nämlich
super schnell meine mutter schätzung ein
bisschen warm geworden ich hatte nämlich
draußen vergessen
am besten lasse die im kühlschrank bis
er sie braucht aber das dürfte jetzt
auch kein problem sein
und ich gebe da auch wie ich schon
gesagt hat ein bisschen von dem
vanilleschoten extrakt dazu einfach so
für den geschmack damit das ganze so ein
bisschen aroma bekommt
und jetzt wird es einfach so kurz wie
möglich verrührt vermisst
das reicht schon den rest mache ich
nämlich gleich mit den händen gibt es
jetzt hier kurz in so eine glasschüssel
einfach damit es auch besser sehen könnt
und den rest mache ich jetzt einfach
kurz mit den händen
denn das soll ja einfach so so wissen
streusel artig werden also so viel zu
grob mit den händen verteilt werden
dürfen auch gerne größere stücke mit
drin bleiben und ich denke im winter
kann man sowas zum beispiel auch gut mit
zimt noch ein bisschen herunter arbeiten
und haben richtig schöne filmstar
jetzt zeige ich euch mal meinen hefeteig
muss guck mal wie gut der aufgegangen
ist richtig schön locker und den nehme
ich mir auf meine silikon matte raus am
besten mit einer tankkarte aber ich habe
jetzt irgendwie in der spülmaschine
aber das geht auch so ganz gut weil er
einfach nicht klebt jetzt werde ich
darum 16 portionen aufteilen und es geht
einfach am besten wenn man sich so zum
beispiel so ein kleines eine kleine
lange rolle macht und jetzt teile ich
das erstmal in die hälfte ein
dann noch mal die hälfte
von normalerweise würde ich das jetzt
alles abmessen aber heute nach augenmaß
und dann einfach jedes nochmal in 4
jetzt nehme ich jedes stückchen und
formen so eine kleine kugel draus ohne
das jetzt zu sehr wieder zusammen zu
drücken
einfach damit wir die teilchen gleich
richtig schön rund ausräumen können und
da jetzt einfach am besten wenn man als
basis der kugel hat dann hat man sich
schön rund
und ich nehme jetzt einfach die
frischhaltefolie von vorhin mit dave
auch die schüssel abgedeckt habe und
deckt die kugeln einfach hier kurz ab
während ich arbeite damit jetzt auch
nicht so austrocknen und da gehen wir
jetzt einfach schön sparsam und wie das
alte stück jetzt nehme ich mir einfach
immer eine kugel setzte hier drauf und
gehen sie einfach von beiden seiten und
dann rolle ich das mit einem aus
hollstadt aus so etwa auf hand größe
also so durchmesser dürften jetzt etwas
zu zehn bis zu 5 cm sein könnte auch so
wie sie mit den händen nachhelfen
dann schüttelte ich das mal wieder kurz
ab und setzt hier auf ein vorbereitetes
backblech und da kann es auch nochmal
bisschen schöner aus formen und bevor
ich da jetzt die johannes bei marmelade
und die streusel draufgeht form ich mir
erst mal vier stück dann kann es auch in
der zeit schon wieder ausruhen und dann
kann man gleich das ganze fertig stellen
so sehen die rohlinge jetzt bei mir aus
sag jetzt mal die teiglinge und ich
nehme jetzt meine johannes bei marmelade
und gibt da so ungefähr halben es was du
drauf was da natürlich jetzt auch
richtig schön wenn man jetzt zum
beispiel auch richtige johannes darauf
gibt das finde ich jetzt auch richtig
schön aber ich habe leider kartelle da
war aber auch eine idee unter morath hat
sie sich halt auch so gewünscht einfach
mit marmelade bzw mit gelee und es
verteile ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen
ohne jetzt zu sehr an den rand zu gehen
weil ich will nicht dass es dann später
unterlag ich will einfach dass es hier
in der mitte verteilt ist ich finde
ganze gibt dann auch so einen schönen
geschmack und vor allen dingen ist es
danach richtig schöne farbe unter den
streuseln alternativ könnte man jetzt
natürlich auch eine andere marmelade
nehmen oder pflaumenmus zum beispiel
kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen vor
allem den verbindungen dann mit zimt
aber ich habe mich jetzt einfach für die
johannisbeeren entschieden weil die
schön säuerlich sind und die streusel
und xenia schön süß und ich finde es
passt einfach super dazu
und jetzt nehme ich mir meine streusel
und gebt ihr einfach so ganz locker
drüber und durch die johannes bei
mangelhaften die natürlich auch schön an
dem hefeteig falls er jetzt sagt ich
möchte ganze ohne johannes bei marmelade
machen würde ich empfehlen vorher so ein
bisschen butter drüber zu streichen
einfache mit die streusel dran kleben
bleiben optimal wie hübsch das aussieht
jetzt schon
jetzt lasse ich dich so einfach noch mal
etwa 20 bis 25 minuten aufgeben bevor
ich sie backen denn ich möchte dass
meine steuerzahler so richtig schön
leicht und locker und flockig platten
die erste film eine stolze zahl lasse
jetzt bereits zum backen
hier kann man deutlich sehen diese
aufgegangen sind im vergleich staat so
habe ich jetzt hier noch die portion die
jetzt gleich noch aufgehen muss also man
sieht hier sind sie noch flach und dann
gehen so richtig schön auf das heißt sie
werden gleich richtig schön weich und
ich werde jetzt im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 200 grad für etwa zwölf minuten
backen ihr müsst einfach darauf achten
dass sie jetzt nicht zu dunkel werden
aber einfach so eine schöne goldgelbe
farbe bekommen und dann werde ich ihnen
derzeit schon mal meinen puderzucker
chris vorbereiten und dann kann man
gleich die warmen strahlen freue ich
mich schon meine streiche talas sie
jetzt fertig gebacken und so sehen sie
jetzt auch selber sondern richtig schöne
goldgelbe farbe auch von unten wie man
sehen kann und ich bereit jetzt während
die noch schön warm sind nun mal den
zuckerguss bau dafür nehme ich einfach
eine zitrone und habe hier ungefähr so
ein bisschen mehr als 100 gramm
puderzucker und gebt da jetzt den
zitronensaft von der halben zitrone ein
bisschen so etwa drei esslöffel und ihr
dürft natürlich auch wenn ihr jetzt das
mit der säure nicht wollt einfach wasser
nehmen oder milch zum beispiel
aber ich bin es einfach eine zitrone
viel leckerer weil das so noch mal so
ein bisschen die säure reinbringt und es
passt einfach gut zu den süßen streuseln
und 100 einfach alles ab
und es wird jetzt kurz glatt gerührt so
dass keine klümpchen mat drin sind
und ich gebe es noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft dazu damit einfach nicht zu
dick ist soll er schön laufen
so und jetzt hat die richtige konsistenz
läuft vom löffel runter und jetzt gibt
es direkt überm einer warmen streusel
thaler
jetzt können dass entweder komplett
damit überziehen aber ich mag das auch
beim bäcker netto wenn sie so zu viel
puderzucker groß drauf haben
deswegen lasse ich das jetzt hier mit
einem löffel einfach so drüber laufen
und ihr seht bei mir sind die streusel
ein bisschen zu erlaufen
es kommt jetzt daher weil ich meine
streusel hat meine mutter war ein
bisschen warm deswegen achtet darauf
dass die butter richtig kalt ist dann
bleiben sie auch richtig formstabil
und so sehen jetzt meine fertigen
streitet alle aus und ich bin kratzer
auf einer platte serviert sehen die
richtig gut aus und ich glaube genau so
gut wie sie riechen und schmecken
guck mal den lockeren hefeteig
und ich bin so ein warmer streusel
thaler zum frühstück schmeckt richtig
gut oder auch einfach mittags zur zum
kaffee oder zum tee und die sind richtig
gut geworden vor allen dingen
diese säure durch den zitronen großes
passt einfach wirklich perfekt ich rate
euch auf jeden fall dieses rezept mal
ausprobieren
das schriftliche rezept gibt es auf
meinem blog this blog de und ihr könnt
mir einfach mal schreiben was ihr noch
für ideen habt mit wasser zum beispiel
diesen streusel thaler noch belegen
könnte
ich finde frische johannisbeeren würden
auch super dazu passen gerade von paar
obendrauf ebenso bald johannes beissel
song ist und ich wünsche euch auf jeden
fall noch ganz viel spaß beim nachhaken
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder
bis bald